[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه نشره التاسعه
هذا المساء مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
[تصفيق]
نحو نهائي المونديال المغرب ياخذ مباراه
تاريخيه امام نظيره الفرنسي
واتحسبا لاعمال شغب قد تصاحب المباراه
السلطات الفرنسيه تنشروا 10 الاف شرطين
نصفهم في باريس
والاخير يصف القرار بالاقصاء السياسي
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا صاربقى باخبار المونديال ومباراه
دور نصف النهائي بين المغرب وفرنسا وتحسبا
لاعمال الشغب تشهد فرنسا تاهبا امنيا وذلك
منذ صباح هذا اليوم رفعت السلطات الفرنسيه
عدد رجال الامن الى 10,000 شرطي من بينهم
5000 في العاصمه باريس ذكر وزير الداخليه
الفرنسيه ان بعض الممرات في اهم شوارع
باريس تغلق انطلاقا من الساعه السادسه
والنصف مساءا لكن في المقابل لا يتم اغلاق
شارع شونزيليزيه الشهير امام حركه المرور
هذا ده وصل قبل قليل الرئيس الفرنسي
مانويل ماكرولي ملعب المباراه لحضور
اللقاء
مغاربه مؤيدين لفريقهم وهذا شيء رائع
بالنسبه لهم لانها المره الاولى التي يصل
فيها فريق افريقي الى هذا الحد القريب جدا
من النهائي
مع الجاليه المغربيه
بثلاثه لكن هذا لطيف للغايه لانها مع
الجاليه المغربيه هنا انها لعبه بين
الاخوه الليله سيكون خصوما في الملعب ولكن
هذا سيتبعه حفل كبير بالفوز
المزيد على كل معنا من الدوحه منفذ
العربيه ليس بازاري ومعنى مشاهدينا من
باريس حسين قنيبر مراسل العربيه ومن رباط
مراسل للعربي عادل الزبيري اهلا بكم جميعا
وابدا من قلب الحدث ابدا من عندك ليث انقل
لنا الاجواء وصل الرئيس الفرنسي ماذا عن
الجانب المغربي ايضا من وصل
ميسون الذي استطيع قوله ان الكثير من
المشجعين المغاربه والعرب وصلوا الى هذا
استاذ استاذ البيت خلف خلفي ولكن الكثير
من الذين وصلوا همم يعني همم
المنتخب المغربي وكذلك شاهدنا قبل قليل
قبل اقل من خمس دقائق نساء افريقيات من
كينيا وصلنا قبل قليل لتسجيع المنتخب
المغربي كما تعلمين لا يوجد منتخبات
افريقيه في تصفيات نهائي كاس العالم هذا
العام
وبالنسبه لهم المغرب هو بلد عربي وافريقي
كذلك وهم اتى ويحملون او يحملون الرايه
المغربيه ولكن يوجد هناك طبعا جنسيات
عربيه مختلفه اكيد انتم من المغرب عندنا
يمكن من السعوديه حضرتك
ان شاء الله بتمثل العرب وان شاء الله
بنروح الرياضيه بالخليج وغير الخليج كل
عربي ما يشجع المغرب ما هو عربي وان شاء
الله اليوم 3-0 للمغرب باذن الله باذن
الله هذا ههه حضرتك انت من المغرب
ميرسي ميرسي يعني الى الامام هذا ما يحتف
المشجعون المغاربه هنا للمنتخب اي الى
الامام حتى تسجيل اهداف واذا اخذنا
الكاميرا ما بعرف قد ايه عندنا وقت ميسون
الكل يعني ما زال هيك برضه كله يسمع اكثر
[تصفيق]
الحمد لله الحمد لله
المصريين سوداني سوري لبنانيين جنسيات
العربيه كامله معنا الحمد لله والدعوه
ديالهم معنا اليوم
فرنسا تقريبا
مساء الخير ميسون اترك الكلمه للصوره
بدايه زميل المصور صبحي
ينقل صوره ما يحصل على الارض
قوات كبيره من الامن الفرنسي في جده بدا
الانتشار قبل قليل هناك على مستوى فرنسا
10 الاف شرطي سيواكبون الاحتفال بنتيجه
مباراه المغرب وفرنسا
وفي باريس وحدها
سينتشر في باريس ومحيطها
و500 عنصر امن
وعندها شهاده سيبلغ عدد المنتشرين حواله
الفي عنصر كما تشاهدين
قوى الامن تتواجد بكثافه عند جده اترك
الكلمه الان للذين سيتابعون هذه المباراه
بونسوار
توقعاتكم لهذه الليله
واحد لمصلحه فرنسا
وهدف للمغرب
اعتقد انه بالتاكيد ستحصل هذه المواجهات
ايفو
ميرسي ميرسي هذا بعضهم من الصوره هنا مع
الاشاره
المركزي للاستخبارات الفرنسيه تماما
زميلتنا علا توقعت اثنان واحد لصالح
المغرب الذين التقيت بهما الفتاتان اللتان
التقد بهما يتوقعون العكس تماما اثنان
لفرنسا وواحد للمغرب بالعوده الى ما ذكرته
الاستخبارات الفرنسيه في مذكره داخليه
توقعت حصول بعض الاضطرابات في كل من
ستراسبور شرقا ميرسيليا ومونبوليا جنوبا
واليوم في الجنوب الشرقي وتركوا وليل في
الشمال ولكن مع ذلك بعض الذين يراقبون
الاستعدادات الامنيه يقللون من احتمالات
حصول مواجهات كبيره وان كانت مصادر تحدث
الليله مصادر امنيه عن انتشار مجموعه من
اليمين المتطرف تن والقيام بدوريات في
شوارع ستراسبور تحسبا لقيام همم جمهور
معين بحسب اليمين المتطرف باثاره
الاضطرابات على اتهامات متبادله باثاره
فوضى ولكن من يثير الفوضى هم مجموعات
قلويه جدا لا علاقه لها بالضروره بجمهور
هذا المنتخب
ليث ساخنه جدا هناك من يريد الحديث وهناك
من يغني ننقل سريعا ليس ايه الصوره من
عندك باختصار الله يخليك
[موسيقى]
باشكال مختلفه هنا في محيط استاذ البيت
الكثير من الشباب المغربي يهتف هتافات
مختلفه قبل شوي
تحيا المغرب
لعبوا عليها وجيبوها ههه
[تصفيق]
مرحبا ميسون عندما اسال المغاربه لماذا
تكونون باردين في الامسيات يقولون نترك
الافراح الى النهايه نحن الان في شارع
محمد الخامس في قلب العاصمه المغربيه
الرباط القلب النابض لاحتفالات وامسيات
المغاربه وسندخل الى هذه المقهى لناخذ بعض
الاراء من المشاهدين المغاربه المقاهي
المغربيه هي المكان المفضله التشجيع معي
مجموعه من المشجعين المغاربه جيل مونديال
مكسيكو 86 هل يكون جيل
2022 هو الجيل الذهبي لكره القدم المغربيه
وما هي توقعاتكم شيء اكيد ان الجيل ديال
2022 هو الشيء المتميز رغم انه لكل لكل
جيل له رجاله ولهذا فنحن جد فخورين ان شاء
الله نتمنى للمغرب نتيجه ايجابيه واستمرار
حتى
نكسب الرهان ان شاء الله
ونفرحها جميع اخواننا العرب والمسلمين
وفارقه توقع للمباراه اليوم وهمم رسالتك
الوليد الركراكي ووليداته الحقيقه هذا يوم
تاريخي يوم عظيم نظرا لان الفريق الوطني
قبل البلاء الحسن وشرف بالكره العربيه
والكره الافريقيه في الحقيقه اليوم همم
انا جد متفائل ان شاء الله وباخصوص بقياده
وليد الركراكي بالحقيقه اللي اعتاد دروس
كثيره دروس كثيره في كره القدم وفي الحياه
وفي كل شيء فالحقيقه اتمنى ان شاء الله
اليوم ان يلعب بنفس الطريقه ونفس طاكتيك
من اجل الفوز ان شاء الله والفوز حاليا
باذن الله توقعات في هذه المباراه اول مره
في نصف النهائي لاول مره يواجه فرنسا ان
شاء الله
بواحد نصيف ان شاء الله
حسين عندي سؤال في ما يتعلق بالاعلام
الاعلام الغربي كان قاسم بعض الشيء فيه
بعض الدول المانيا منها ايضا نتحدث عن
اسبانيا ويقال فرنسا كانت قاسيه ايضا على
المنتخب المغربي اعطينا صوره سريعه حسين
عن التغطيه الاعلاميه حول هذه المباراه
تحديدا
وسائل الاعلام الفرنسيه ليس بالضروره قسوه
وانتقادا للمنتخب المغربي لكن بعض وسائل
الاعلام هنا ركزت على الكون العالم العربي
متضامنا مع المغرب ركز كثيرا على هذه
الناحيه واستضيفت بعض الشخصيات لتشرح
لماذا يقف الشارع العربي مع المغرب الى
هذا الحد علما انه ليس بالضروره ان كل
الفرنسيين من اصول عربيه يقفون حتما
وتلقائيا مع المغرب طبعا الغالبيه تقف مع
المغرب لكنه هناك من الفرنسيين من اصول
عربيه من اختاره ان يؤيد المنتخب الذي
يعتبره الافضل او الاكثر استحقاقا اذا
الاعلام الفرنسي تعاطى من زاويه ان الشارع
العربي يؤيد المنتخب المغربي على نطاق
واسع ولم تكن هناك قسوه بمعنى القسوه على
اداء المنتخب المغربي على العكس من ذلك
وسائل اعلام فرنسيه اعربت عن اعجابها
بالمسار الذي سلكه المنتخب المغربي وصولا
الى نصف النهائي وهذه السابقه الفريق
المغربي يواجه الليله المنتخب المغربي
يواجه منتخب فرنسيه فاز بكاس العالم
مرهتين الاولى عام 98 ضد البرازيل ثلاثه
اهداف في فرنسا مقابل لا شيء للبرازيل
والمره الثانيه عام 2018 عندما فازت فرنسا
باربعه اهداف مقابل هدفين لكرواتيا في
المونديال الذي جرى في روسيا قبل اربع
سنوات ميسون وتشاهدين الاجراءات الامنيه
التي تحدثت عنها مكثفه جدا
وليس اعود اليه لانه الاجواء ساخنه هناك
ويبدو انه في طفل متواجد يريد ان يواجه
كلمه للمنتخب اتوقع ان يكون للمنتخب
المغربي ليس
نعم للمنتخب المغربي وهو عبد العزيز من
المدينه المنوره في السعوديه عبد العزيز
كيف بتشجع المنتخب المغربي انت
كيف شو بتعمل
صار عندهم
يحتفلون وكذا يعني احتفل معهم واحضر معهم
مباريات
على كاس العالم والمونديال الذي يقام هنا
في قطر ومدى ذلك تغيرت الصوره 180 درجه
عندما شاهدنا الاعلام الفرنسي خصوصا
القنوات الفرنسيه التي وصلت عندما بدا
المنتخب الفرنسي يفوز ويتقدم نحو النهائي
في كاس العرب
البيضاء عرفنا عن الاوضاع من عندك
والاجواء الخليل
الان الان المغاربه الكثير منهم متجهه الى
المقاهي والى ساحات عمل المشجعين لمتابعه
المباريات هم يقولون انهم اكملوا
استعداداتهم للفرح هم متاكدونا ان اسود
الاطلس هذه الليله سيهزمون الديوك
الفرنسيه همم
نتوقع ان تكون هناك احتفالات غير مسبقه
اذا ما تمكن المنتخب المغربي من التاهل
الى الدور النهائي في هذه البطوله نتحدث
الى الناس الى المشجعين همم
[موسيقى]
ونحن واقفون على قدم وساق لتشجيع المنتخب
الوطني وكلنا امل ان شاء الله
ان كل شرائح المجتمع المغربي وجميع فئات
المجتمع المغربي مهتم بمشاركه ممثل المغرب
في هذه البطوله ويتابعونها
بالتفاصيل همم هناك تفاؤل كبير او لن نشكر
جميع همم وس
ائل طبقه ان شاء الله لغتكون ما بين
اسبانيا والمغرب اكيد غاتكون صعيبه ولكن
ان شاء الله اه اوه سوري فرنسا ههه
اسبانيا ان شاء الله غادي نفوزوا بجوج
وزيرو وشكرا على هذا الفرحه وعلى هذا
العرس العالمي والافريقي
والعربيات كانت شوارع بدات تخلو من الماره
ومن السيارات
وايضا من عادل الزبير شكرا جزيلا لكم
جميعا
طبعا المشاهدين عاده ما يعرف جمهور كل
فريق او منتخب بانه اللاعب رقم 12 لكن
الجمهور المغربي وخلال المونديال الحالي
كسر القاعده اثبت انه اللاعب رقم 1 مش 12
ففي موعد تاريخي سيقف منتخب المغرب على
اعتاب نهائي اغلى المسابقات الكرويه حاملا
فوق عاتقه امل جماهير بلاده وايضا جماهير
عربيه واخرى افريقيا منذ انطلاق مونديال
قطر لكره القدم كانت كلمه السر بالنسبه
لاسود الاطلسيه الجمهور المغربي الذي
تزايد زخمه مع التاهل لدوره ثمن ربع
النهائي واليوم في المباراه المصيريه التي
ستجمعه بنظيره الفرنسيه الاسود يخططون
لمواصله المغامره الموندياليه وحجم مكان
في النهائي معاولينا طبعا على الجماهير
العريضه التي كان لديها دور كبير في
نجاحات المنتخب المغربي والتي اثبتت كما
ذكرنا بان اللاعب رقم واحد في تشكيله وليد
لرجيه منذ بدايه المونديال من المتوقع
حضور اكثر من 20,000 مشجع مغربي بعد ان
خصصت الرباط جسرا جويا لنقل انصار المنتخب
المغربي الى الدوحه طبعا اضافه للالاف من
العرب والافارقه الذين من المتوقع ان
يساند اسود الاطلس وفقا لارقام احصائيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
طبعا مشاهدينا الصور التي نشاهدها الان في
هذه اللحظات هي صور مباشره تاتينا من
الدوحه حيث هذه المباراه طبعا الكل
ينتظرها هذه صور مباشره من احدى نقاط
التشجيع وطبعا الاعلام المغربيه جمهور
المغرب يتواجد في هذه النقطه تحديدا
[موسيقى]
طبعا مشاهدينا حضور جماهيري لمباريات
المغرب كان لافت جدا نبدا بالمباراه التي
جمعت اسود الاطلس مع نظيره البرتغالي فيها
تجاوز عدد المشجعين عدد ثبت ال 44 الف
اغلبهم طبعا مشجعين المنتخب اما في
المباراه التي كانت مع المنتخب الاسباني
فلقد زاد عدد المشجعين عن
44,500 مشجع اغلبهم ايضا من انصار اسود
الاطلس المنتخب المغربي يتمتع بخط دفاع
قوي حيث لم تتلقى شباكه هو هدف واحد طبعا
جاء خطا في مرمى كما انه حافظ على نظافه
شباكه في اربع مباريات من اصل الخمس
مباريات خاضها لحد الان سجل المنتخب
المغربي خمسه اهداف في البطوله بينما وقع
نظيره الفرنسي احد عشر هدفا انطلقت شباكه
اربع اهداف كما انه تلقى الهزيمه في
مباراته الثالثه امام المنتخب التونسي
علما انه كان متاهل
فبعد الانجاز غير المسبوق ببلوغ المربع
الذهبي يمكن للمغرب ان يعول على دعم قاره
باكملها يحمل امالها من خلال تحدي اصحاب
اللقب السابق للوصول الى النهائي في عالم
الساحره المستديره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في التاسعه هذا المساء ولكن بعد قليل
تخوفا من سيناريو ضربه نوويه العاصمه
الاوكرانيه تجهز الملاجئ
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا قال رئيس بلديه اسطنبول
اكرم امام اوغلو في اول تعليق له بعد حكم
السجنه قال انه لا يمكن لاحد ان ياخذ
السلطه التي يمنحها الناخبون وصفا الحكم
الصادر بحقه بغير القانوني طبعا هذه
التصريحات جاءت بعد انقدت محكمه تركيا
بسجن رئيس بلديه اسطنبول المعارض عامين
وسبعه اشهر وبينما اكد محامي اكرم امام
اوغلو انهم سيستانفون ضد الحكم الذي صدر
بحق رئيس بلديه اسطنبول قال زعيم المعارضه
التركيه معلقا على الحكم قال ان البلاد
تشهد اغتيال القانون وتعفن اداره الدوله
استسلمت لاراده الشخص على حد وصفه
المزيد معنا من اسطنبول مراسل العربيه
زيدان زينجو اهلا بك زيدان اعطينا فكره
وخلفيه حول هذا القرار وتابعاته
هذا القرار سياسيه اكثر منها قانونيا
سياسيه هي ضربه للمعارضه من قبل الحكومه
التركيه وحسب العداله والتنميه الحاكم اما
من الناحيه القانونيه وكما كنت اتابع
تصريحات لبعض الحقوقيين قبل قليل كان هناك
حديث ان هذا القانون او القرار عفوا لن
ينفذ قبل همم مصادقه عليه من محكمه
الاستئناف والمحكمه العليا وهذا يعني ان
هذا الموضوع او قرارات التصديق قبل
المحكمتين ستستغرق وقتا اطول من همم
الموعد المحدد للانتخابات وبالتالي فرصه
اكرم امام اوغلو في حال اراد الترشح
للانتخابات القادمه ستكون قائمه طالما ان
محكمه الاستئناف والمحكمه همم العليا لم
تصدر قرارا نهائيا في هذا همم في هذه
القضيه لكن كما نعلم ان موضوع الترشح اكثر
من امام اوه حتى الان هو مستعد واا اغلب
همم الترجيحات تشير الى ان زعيم المعارضه
هو من سيترشح لمنافسه الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان لكن بغض النظر عن هويه المرشح
القادم للمعارضه تبعات القرار السياسيه
بامتياز سيكون لهذا القرار صدى واسع في
الشارع التركي كان هناك ادانات من قبل
رئيس التركي السابق عبد الله جول ادانا
هذا القرار
بهمني اعرف ردود الفعل على مستوى الشارع
وعلى المستوى السياسي والمسؤولين
نعم
طبعا مسؤوليه حزب العداله والتنميه
والشركه في الاختلاف الحاكم حسب الحركه
القوميه كان هناك من قبل احزاب المعارضه
وقاده الاحزاب المعارضه بشكل كبير لهذا
القرار ايضا شاهدنا اذانات من قبل بعض
النقابات والمنظمات المهنيه وايضا الرئيس
التركي السابق عبد الله جول الذي قال ان
هذا القرار ليس ظلما فقط لاكرم امام اوغلو
وانما لتركيا بكاملها واتمنى ان تبطل
المحكمه العليا هذا القرار همم على مستوى
الشارع كان هناك تضامن همم من مغردين
اتراك وبشكل واسع على تويتر قبل قليل
شاهدنا عده همم او عده تغريدات كانت تدعم
اكرم امام اوغلو وكان هناك الحديث بانه لن
يكون وحيدا في هذه القضيه انما جزء من
الشارع التركي
في هذه القضيه لذلك كما قلت القضيه
السياسيه قبلها ابعاد سياسيه كبيره سيكون
لها صدى لا بلا شك على الحملات الانتخابيه
للمعارضه التي
ستستثمر همم او ستستفيد من هذه القضيه
بشكل كبير في حملاتها الانتخابيه القادمه
لاسيما بين اوساط حزب العداله والتنميه
وانصار حزب العداله والتنميه همم التي
تستعد لخوض الانتخابات بعد حوالي سته اشهر
من الان بالعموم القضيه كما ذكرت همم او
وضع السياسي في تركيا لن يكون كما كان
عليه قبل قرار المحكمه هذا اليوم
شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
يواجه قرابه العشرين ايراني من بينهم طبيب
وفنانين وايضا لاعب كره قدم عقوبه الاعدام
التي تستخدمها السلطات الايرانيه وسيله
للترحيب بهدف يقمع الاحتجاجات طبعا بحسب
مجموعات حقوقيه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا عدد الصحفيين المسجونين في
العالم بصوره عامه وصل الى مستوى قياسي
جديد خلال العام
533 صحفي تم اعتقالهم وتم سجنهم طبعا
بالنسبه لايران اشاره الاحصائيه الى قيام
النظام الايراني باعتقالات كثيره بين
الصحفيين منذ بدء التظاهرات في سبتمبر
الماضي كما تشير الحصيله الى ارتفاع عدد
الصحفيين الذين قتلوا الى 57 بسبب الحرب
في اوكرانيا المنظمه لفت ضمن هذا التعداد
العالمي الى عدد غير مسبوق من النساء
المسجونات بحوالي 15% مقارنه اقل من سبعه
بالمئه قبل خمس سنوات
[موسيقى]
هذا وضعت ليندا توم
واشنطن في الامم المتحده الى طرد ايران من
عضويه هيئه وضع المراه التابع طبعا للامم
المتحده قالت انه على المجتمع الدولي
مساعده النساء والفتيات في ايران من عمليه
القمع والتصفيه التي يتعرضن لها بحسب
تعبيرها
فرصه كبيره للقيام
يمكننا من دعم النساء
الايرانيات معنا في هذه الجلسات لنتصرف
بشكل سليم تجاه النساء والفتيات في ايران
والعالم من اجل النساء والحياه والحريه
[موسيقى]
مع تواصل العمليات العسكريه الروسيه على
الاراضي الاكرانيه نشرت صحيفه نيوز بيك
نقل عن مسؤولين امريكيين ان روسيا تسعى
للحصول على ذخائر السلاح من كوريا
الشماليه في الوقت الذي تستنزف فيه معركه
ضخمت مخزون الولايات المتحده البنتاجون
اكد بان موسكو تتجه الى كوريا الشماليه
للحصول على امدادات الذخيره من كوريا
الشماليه لمحاوله اكتساب قدره اضافيه في
اوكرانيا مسؤول امريكا قال بان روسيا
ستفافح لتجديد ذخيره المدفعيه والصواريخ
الصالحه للخدمه بالكامل من خلال الموردين
الاجانب وزياده الانتاج المحلي والتجديد
هذا بعد اكثر من تسعه اشهر على بدايه
العمليات العسكريه الروسيه على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه تواصل القوات الروسيه كفاحها
من اجل تحقيق اهداف جوهريه الكساندر
خداكوفسكي قائد القوات الروسيه في دمشق
قال ان استخدام الاسلحه النوويه قد يكون
الطريقه الوحيده التي يمكن ان تساعد الجيش
الروسي تحقيق انتصارات ومكاسب ميدانيه في
اوكرانيا القائد العسكري الروسيه اشار الى
ان السلطات العسكريه الروسيه تدرك ان
مواردها لها حدود بما يشير الى انها قد
تضطر الى اللجوء الى الاسلحه النوويه
لهزيمه اوكرانيا اكد ان روسيا يمكن ان
تنشر اسلحه نوويه اذا تجاوزته حدودا معينه
واصبح منخرطا مباشره وبشكل مباشره في
الصراع العسكريه
[موسيقى]
طبعا مشاهدينا هذا عن النوايا النوويه
لبعض القاده الروس ولكن ماذا عن استعدادات
الاوكرانيين المخوف من سيناريو الحرب
النوويه تتزايد والملاجئ وايضا حقائب
الظهر واجهزه الراديو باتت هي الحل الوحيد
وذلك للنجاح اصبحت حقيبه
ظهر مضاده للاشعه النوويه مليئه بالمؤن
وادوات البقاء على قيد الحياه والعديد
ايضا من الاحتياطات الممثله اصبحت الطريقه
الوحيده التي يمكن ان يعتمد عليها
الاوكرانيون في حال نفذ الجيش الروسي ضربه
نوويه طبعا وفقا لتقرير صادر عن واشنطن
بوست فان العشرات من المواطنين
الاوكرانيين
وذلك داخل المنازل منازلهم وحتى في اماكن
عملهم تحسبا لاي ضربه نوويه روسيه وبدرجات
متفاوته يفكر سكان كيف في الاحتمال الذي
لم يكن من اليوم يمكن او من الممكن تص في
السابق بان مدينتهم يمكن ان تكون مستهدفه
بقنبله نوويه طبعا بالنسبه للعديد من سكان
اكيف فان المخاطر الروسيه كافيه لتمرير
بعض خطط الطوارئ حيث تم تجهيز نتحدث عن
حوالي 425 ماوى اضافي في كياب لخدمه اولئك
الذين يعيشون خارج المدينه
الملاجئ لا يكون بها متسائل للجميع سوف
يقوم باغلاق ابوابها قبل خمس دقائق من اي
انفجار متوقع طبعا لحمايه من بداخلها من
تداعيات الاشعاع الواشنطن بوست ايضا اشارت
الى ان كيف تمتلك بالفعل شبكه من الملاجئ
الجاهزه للطاقه النوويه في شكل نظام مترو
الانفاق الخاص بها والتي تم تشيدها في
الحقبه السوفياتيه والموجوده على عمق 346
قدم تحت الارض
[موسيقى]
طبعا توتر في الميدان يقابله عمليه تبادل
الاسرى بين كيف و موسكو اعلنت الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه الافراج عن 64 اوكرانيا
وامريكا واحد قال مدير مكتب الرئيس
الاوكرانيه
64 جنديا من القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
الذين قاتلوا في منطقه
خصوصا يعودونا الى وطنهم مشيرا الى امريكا
او امريكا
[موسيقى]
التقى وزير الدفاع السعوديه الامير خالد
بن سلمان بنظيره البريطاني بنولس ناقش
الاوضاع على المستويين الاقليمي وايضا
الدوله كما وقعت وزاره الدفاع السعوديه مع
الدفاع البريطانيه خطه للتعاون الدفعي من
شانها ان تسهم في تعزيز تعزيز قدراتي
وزاره الدفاع السعوديه ورفع كفاءتها ونقل
المعرفه والتدريب وتوطين الصناعات
العسكريه بحسب ماشر الامير خالد بن سلمان
في التاسعه هذا المساء ولكن بعد قليل
اضراب عمال السكك الحديديه في بريطانيا
يدخل يومه الثاني والبلاد بدون قطارات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا الى نشره المساء تغير
الدراماتيكي في سياسه الصين تجاه وباء
كورونا يتجه نحو الرعايه الذاتيه وايضا
تخفيف القيود الصارمه التي فرضتها الحكومه
منذ ثلاثه سنوات تغير خلق مخاوف لدى منظمه
الصحه العالميه من انتشار موج جديده
للفيروس متابعه
ثلاث سنوات مرت على ظهور الوباء الاكثر
انتشارا منذ عقود منطلقا من الصين اتخذت
فيها دول العالم اقصى الاجراءات من حجر
صحيا واختبارات قصريه لفيروس كورونا هذه
الاجراءات المشدده استمرت في الصين حتى
بعد ان فتحت مطارات العالم وتعافت معظم
البلدان لترفع الحكومه الصينيه القيود
مؤخرا عوده حذره الى الحياه الطبيعيه
تعيشها الصين رغم ان نسبه الاصابات قلت
والفايروس تحت السيطره الا ان تحضيرات
عديده رفعت الرايه الحمراء
منظمه الصحه العالميه حذرت من العوده
المفاجئه ورفع القيود الكبيره من الصعب
دائما على اي بلد ان يخرج من وضع تسوده
الضوابط الصارمه للغايه الصين تواجهه
اوقات صعبه وصعبه جدا انخفاض كبير في عدد
الاصابات المسجله الا انه تزامن مع
الانخفاض في اجراء الفحوصات بالرغم من ذلك
لم تبلغ الصين عن اي حاله وفاه منذ الثالث
من ديسمبر اي قبل تخفيف القيود 50 اصابه
خطيره في مشافي بكين تبدو رقما صغيرا
بالنسبه لعدد سكان الصين الا ان المخاوف
من موجه جديده ما تزال قائمه تحول كبير في
نهج الحكومه الصينيه تجاه السيطره على
الفيروس بعد ان استبعدت مبنى مناعه القطيع
وزادت الضغوطات بغرض الحمايه من العدوى
حيث يتجه اليوم مسؤول صحه الصينيون الى
فكره الرعايه الذاتيه
مع دخول اضراب عمال السكك الحديديه في
بريطانيا يومه الثاني انضم لهم اليوم عمال
البريد مطالبين بتحسين الاجور وايضا شروط
العمل الاضراب اوقف العمل باكثر من نصف
الخطوط الحديديه كما توقفت بشكل تام في
اسكتلندا وويلز ايضا قطاع التمريض دخل على
خط الاضراب بالتوقفي عن العمل في المشافي
والمؤسسات التابعه لخدمه الصحه الوطنيه
بدءا من ال 21 من ديسمبر للمطالبه بزياده
الاجور بنسبه 19% فيما تحاول الحكومه
البريطانيه مواجهه هذه التحديات بعقد
اجتماعات طارئه بهدف التخفيف من تداعيات
الاضرابات خاصه
بالتزامن مع فتره الاعياد في المملكه
المتحده
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا ماء الزهق جديد يواجه تطبيق تيك
توك في الولايات المتحده ليعود بذلك
التطبيق الصيني مره اخرى الى قفص
الاتهامات بالتجسس ومعها ترتفع وتيره
المحاوف الامريكيه من هذا التطبيق هذه
المخاوف دفعتها سنتر الجمهوري ماركو روبيو
للكشف عن تشريع مدعوم من اعضاء الحسبين
الجمهوري والديمقراطي لحضر تطبيق التواصل
الاجتماعي الشهير تيك توك تشريع يزيد
الضغط على شركه باي دانس المالكه للتطبيق
مخاوف امريكيه من امكانيه استخدام التطبيق
في التجسس على الامريكيين هذا المشروع
الجديد ياتي والمدعون من اعضاء في الحزبين
كما ذكرنا بعد ان شاركت كل من اداره
الرئيس الامريكي الحالي جو بايدن والسابق
دونالد ترامب بخوف بشان التطبيق ومخاطره
الامنيه الاجراءات الامريكيه لن تقتصر على
تطبيق تيك توك فقط بل ستشمل ايضا تطبيقات
صينيه اخرى للتواصل الاجتماعي وحتى
التطبيقات الروسيه لن تفلت من التشريع
الامريكي هذا
عن وفقا لاكسيوس وقد ساعدت عدد من
الولايات المتحده بما في ذلك يتا
وماريلاند وتكسس بالفعل الى حضر استخدام
تيك توك في الوكالات الحكوميه طبعا عن رده
فعل تيك توك قال متحدث باسم تيك توك في
بيان انه بدلا من تشجيع الاداره على
استكمال مراجعتها ذات الصله بالامن القومي
لتيك توك قرر بعض اعضاء الكونجرس الضغط من
اجل حضر
[موسيقى]
التطبي
المزيد معنا من واشنطن مراسله العربيه
ريتا سليمان اهلا بك ريتا ريتا بدايه ما
الذي اعد طرح هذا الملف مجددا بهذه القوه
المخاوف التي اثارها بيان مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدراليه الشهر الماضي حول الكون تيك
توك اداه تجسس صينيه اعاد هذا الجدل
بضروره حضر هذا التطبيق امريكيا مشرعون
كما ذكرت ميسون من الحزبين الجمهوري
والديمقراطي تحت قبه الكونغرس ان كان من
مجلس النواب او من مجلس الشيوخ همم تحدثوا
بعد هذا البيان من الاف- على وضع تشريع
لحضر تيك توك لحمايه الامريكيه لانه
البيانات اثبتت انه
يتابع بيانات
الامريكين صغارا وكبارا طبعا انه همم هذه
التشريعات وهم من وقت البيان تحديدا وقبل
هذا التشريع شن- ال- اا المشرعون حمله على
وسائل همم الاعلام المحليه لتوعيه ولحاث
المواطنين الامريكيين لعدم استخدام تيك
توك وقالوا بانه لا يتعلق فقط بالمحتوى
الذي يحملونه على التطبيق لان التطبيق
يجمع بياناتهم صور وجههم
على ليس فقط حظر هذا التطبيق بل بالحصول
على هاتف جديد تماما بعد حضر التطبيق همم
هذا
التحرك وهذه الحمله اليس من المفترض بانها
تتزامن مع تحرك من اداره بيض
لتوقيع اتفاقيه والوصول الى اتفاقيه مع
الصين بهذا الاطار
صحيح واا اداره بيضا تطمح بتوقع اتفاقيه
مع شركه تيك توك نفسها شركات تيك توك كانت
ذكرت بانها همم
تدرس مشروع تكساس وهو مشروع قانون يسمح
لها
بحمايات بيانات المستخدمين الامريكيين فقط
الموظفين في الولايات المتحده يطلعوا على
هذه البيانات الخاصه بالمواطنين
الامريكيين بما يسمح بالاجابه على المخاوف
الامنيه والقوميه الامريكيه همم
بيان شركه تيك توك تحديدا وبالتالي مثل
هذا التحرك هل له ان يؤثر على هذه
الاتفاقيه او حتى على العلاقات الصينيه
الامريكيه خاصه انه بالفتره الاخيره كان
في نوع من التحرك بالصداع ليس كذلك او على
الاقل تخفيف التوتر بين الدولتين
نعم صحيح خاصه مع اعلان عن زياره وزير
الخارجيه اعطوني بلنكن الى الصين في العام
المقبل بدايه العام المقبل وجهنا هذا
السؤال للمشرعين الامريكيين في الكونغرس
وقالوا بانه اييي هذه التشريعات لن يتم
التصويت عليها حتى اسابيع مقبله لم يحددوا
سقف زمني لها ربما للسماح بعدم تاثيرها
على زياره وزير الخارجيه الى الصين بحسب
ما قالوا لنا مراقبين ومتابعين لملفات
الكونجرس وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه وايضا
حسب متابعتنا لكل الاجراءات التي تم
اتخاذها امريكيا تيك توك في سنوات الماضيه
تبعنا ايضا همم اجابه الصين على هذه
الاجراءات وكانت فقط توجيه الانتقادات
بانه هذا يمس حريه الراي همم
الولايات المتحده من واشنطن مراسله
العربيه يا ريت شكرا جزيلا لك
في امريكا ايضا خسائر في القروض ستصاب بها
بعض المصارف التي اقرضت الى الماسك
الملياردير الامريكي 13 مليار دولار لشراء
تويتر حيث تتبع المصارف اليه تبيع القروض
للمستثمرين الا انه في حاله التويتر ستصل
الخسائر الى المليارات اذا تم اتباعه تلك
الاليه اذ لن يقوم المستثمرون بشراء
القروض في الوضع الحالي الحساس للطائر
الازرق بعد ان توقف المعلنون عن الاعلان
على المنصه
[موسيقى]
اعلن رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي ابيب
قهفي اعلن مسؤوليه اسرائيل عن تنفيذ غاره
طالت شاحنتين من اصل 25 شاحنه عند دير
الزور على الحدود العراقيه السوريه قبل
اقل من شهر وقد برر مراقبون اسرائيل هذا
الموقف بانه محاوله لردع ايران لمنعها
ايضا من الاقدام على تهريب المزيد من
الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه والدقيقه زياد حلبي
مع التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
الهدوء
للجبهه الشماليه عاده خادعا فليس بعيدا
تدور ما تسميها اسرائيل بالمعركه بين
الحروب بينها وبين ايران حيث تستهدف
اسرائيل ما تقول انه مواقع ايرانيه او
شحنات اسلحه دقيقه واستراتيجيه معده لحزب
الله معركه سريه القاعده فيها عدم
الاعتراف بالغارات منعا لاحراج الطرف
الاخر وجره للرد لهذا فان التبني رئيس
الاركان الاسرائيلي لهجوم دير الزور كان
لافتا يخلو الولد ده كان من الممكن ان لا
نعرف قبل بضعه اسابيع عن القافله السوريه
المتجهه من العراق الى سوريا وكان من
الممكن ان لا نعرف ما كان فيها وان لا
نعرف ايضا انه من بين 25 شاحنه فان
الشاحنه رقم ثمانيه هي الشاحنه التي تقل
الوسائل القتاليه
ورغم تصريحات كوخابي ايضا بان اسرائيل
عرقله التموضع الايراني خاصه نشر صواريخ
ارجو في سوريا ولبنان ومحاوله انشاء حزب
الله سوري على تخوم الجولان فان الغارات
لا تتوقف وقد تتكثف لخشيه اسرائيل من ان
تستغل ايران تعاونها مع روسيا في الحرب
على اوكرانيا لتعميق طموضوعها في سوريا
حيث نشرت بطاريات دفاع جوي في محيط دمشق
بمثابه رسائل تحضيريه ربما
يبرر تصريحات اجرها اليوم التي تاتي على
خلفيه الانباء حول احتمال استخدام مطار
بيروت لنقل الاسلحه اللي حزب الله هذا
الامر يخلق الصعيد سوريا تشكل عمليا ساحه
المواجهه المباشره بين اسرائيل وايران حيث
باتت الجبهه الشماليه موحده بين سوريا
ولبنان
ما تسميها اسرائيل بالمعركه بين الحروب
والتي تشمل سوريا ولبنان والعراق ودول
اخرى هي حرب ظلال تهدف اسرائيليا الى مرعي
ايران من اقامه جبهه قتاليه لاستخدامها في
الحرب المقبله ويحاطه اسرائيل باسلحه
استراتيجيه او دقيقه زياد حلب بالعربيه
القدس الغربيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
امام نظيره الفرنسي
وتحسبا لاعمال شغب قد تصاحب المباراه
سلطات الفرنسيه تنشروا 10000 شرطين نصفهم
في باريس
والاخير يصف القرار بالاقصاء السياسي
طبعا مشاهدينا انا محظوظه رح اروح احضر
المباراه اما راويه فباقي معك 360
راويه وينك
انا رايحه احضر المباراه
والحماس من ورق الشجر يلا يعطيك العافيه
شكرا